Horner's [ __ ] more on what are you  never mind never mind just forget it  who's your guy yakking at your door just  mind your own business will you mind  your own business mind your own business  traveling with the child use the  restroom good point I need to take a  pee-pee I never complain where do I  complain about you practicing the violin  at 3:00 in the morning or your mess  you're a general lack of hygiene or the  fact that you steal my clothes I am NOT  your mother I'm your partner  let go  it's terrific like what why you just  feed me to the Lions stuff on my head  when I'm drowning what a great friend  women what stop this is completely  against the rules  Louie I think this is the beginning of a  beautiful friendship